all right it was uh i appreciate you
guys introducing me to the
wonderful world of okay
so so has this experience
changed your perspective at all or i
mean i still have my preferred methods
yeah right right but i got my systems in
place but would you ever
in your like often i mean go back to
like try another dojo like
if i was recommended uh doujin that was
uh highly praised i i would go and read
it i mean it's not it's not too
difficult
yeah hopefully it's not too long yeah no
i i i would say the biggest appeal
about reading doujins or highly rated
dojinshi is like you
yeah i mean you've talked about finding
that one hentai that's [ __ ] like
like the diamonds in this like [ __ ]
right
there's so much choice with dojinshi
because there's like obviously
so much right infinite amount of time
there's there's way more choice than
there is for hentai
and you can find way more doujins that
are like
specifically garnered to your choice
i just really enjoy voice acting so much
and especially in that manner i really
enjoy what it adds to it
i feel like it helps sell my
believability to me
the best the best tag you can possibly
get is plot
plot is the best spice isn't it tragic
that it has to be a tag though
they're like it's it's not a given that
everything else i don't want plot in my
life yeah somebody was like no
no i don't want the plumber turning up
today i i don't want the pizza man
delivering
but you know the fact that we're talking
about the plumber and the pizza man just
shows
how [ __ ] devoid of plot every [ __ ]
porno is that we've
gotten this kind of mentality where like
almost
plot's kind of hot you know knowing the
context of why people are [ __ ] that's
kind of hot you know
is that it's is that such a hard to me
not being a [ __ ] monkey and just
scratching my nuts to people [ __ ] you
know great fantastic you know wow
my god well i'm just glad connor that we
managed to finally do this episode
because we've been we've been talking
about doing this episode for quite a
while now we were like
yeah two out of three loved ocean monkey
man over here
doesn't want to read i feel at this
point we should just make it like a uh
uh
buy is it buy a yearly buy yeah
yeah this is like about six months after
the hentai episode we'll do another
hentai oh my god it's already been six
months yeah i know right now
[ __ ] much don't we
i can't honestly has been such a [ __ ]
episode it's such a [ __ ] fun episode
[ __ ] episode it has been a [ __ ]
this has been a [ __ ] episode
you know the succubus one i'm praying
gets it oh yeah yeah so
yeah so out of the seven what's your
favorite can i rank them in order sure
all right
metamorphosis is the worst one least
favorite to most favorite it's american
okay so metamorphosis is by far the
worst one
very close last second last place
the [ __ ] orimo one
that's what gone in the bottom so far
yeah um i will
say that probably after that is
oh ah it's gotta be the
the first one yeah yeah yeah that one i
wasn't too fond of
yeah and then third i guess
is this
difficult
i'll give it to the sensei one okay okay
fifth i'll give it to peace peace yeah
and first place over to succubus wow
that's pretty balanced then that's
pretty balanced actually yeah
that's not bad well you recommend the
succubus one right yeah yeah so yeah i'd
say
it's my one yeah i'd say you both gave
me
you know i was shocked i was expecting
worse from you i was expecting
i was expecting lolly orc gangbangs from
jerry
and from i was expecting the whole
family [ __ ] each other thankfully i
mean
i mean we could have recommended that
like we got pretty [ __ ] close with
the original one right
the whole family came up for fun with
that one [ __ ] me and uh you haven't
finished piece of harmony so i'm just
gonna leave that
but the thing is we can only recommend
three so like when you're choosing three
dojinshi that's like a [ __ ] hard
choice
it's like it's it's like it's like
choosing between your children
i was just like i wanted to recommend
like one of the top tier milf ones but
i'm just like
there's not this there's not enough
space you can recommend me like one good
one and two ones that you know i [ __ ]
hate
yeah honestly you know what you can do
give us a list of tags
and we'll find you some milf milf milf
milk step mum step up
step mother knows breast i don't know
you know it's likely i don't like incest
but i'd like to tell you boys
i'm going to go here i'm going to go
home today a changed man
reading dojins but i'm not i'm
definitely not